Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier aus Dienstabendler Arstetik und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analyse-Gespräch führen.
Wenn Sie etwas zu tun haben oder eine Frage haben, können Sie gerne mit mir Bescheid sagen.
Können Sie etwas langsamer sprechen? Sie reden so schnell.
Okay, ja. Alles klar. Und bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Bescheidensprache sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar Algamene Frage an Sie stellen.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Angelika Schmidt.
Angelika Schmidt? Können Sie Ihre Nachname ustabieren?
S-C-H-N-I-D-T.
Okay, D-T. Frau Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 7.08.1968.
Okay, 860. Ja.
Und wie schwer sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 72 Kilogramm schwer.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,74 groß.
Okay, 74.
Okay, schön.
Frau Schmidt, was für Bescheid haben Sie momentan? Was für Sie ist zu uns?
Ich habe jetzt schon beobachtet, dass ich viel mehr gewogen habe.
Meine Körpergewicht war vorher ungefähr bei knapp 85 Kilogramm.
Und ich bin jetzt seit der letzten Zeit immer kontinuierlich, habe ich ein Gewicht verloren.
Also ich bin jetzt schon gesagt, aber ich habe 70 Kilogramm.
Und in den letzten 3 Monaten habe ich ja ungefähr, weiß ich nicht,
über 15 Kilogramm abgenommen tatsächlich.
Und ich kann mir das nicht erklären, woran es liegt.
Was ich aber auch bemerkt habe, ist, dass ich ziemlich müde geworden bin tatsächlich.
Und ich kann meinen Alltag nicht mehr so bewältigen, wie ich vorher das gemacht habe.
Und das macht mir sehr starke Sorgen, wenn ich sage.
Ja, ja, verstehe ich.
Und hat es Sie früher oder seit wann hatten Sie das zu beschwerden?
Ja, also ich habe eigentlich gar keine richtigen Geschwerden.
Ich habe nur, dass ich gemerkt, dass ich Gewicht verloren habe.
Und dass meine Hosen mir nicht mehr passen.
Das habe ich jetzt vor kurzem, vor ein, 2 Wochen bemerkt.
Und dann habe ich mich auf die Waage gestellt und bemerkt,
dass es tatsächlich schon 72 Kilogramm geworden sind.
Und ich habe mir noch nie so gewogen.
Meine Freunden sagten mir, das ist Idealgewicht.
Ich soll mir keine Gedanken machen.
Ich bin ja auch nur 71 groß und warum ich mir Gedanken mache,
aber es macht mir schon Sorgen,
weil ich noch nie so stark ein Gewicht verloren habe.
Genau, ja.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schmerzen?
Ich habe gar keine Schmerzen eigentlich gedacht.
Keine Schmerzen, okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Schüttefrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Also Fieber habe ich nicht wirklich.
Nachtschweiß habe ich jetzt zunehmend gemerkt.
Also in den letzten 2 Wochen, also obwohl ich habe zuerst gedacht,
es war wegen der Wärme, dass es so heiß war draußen,
aber jetzt wo es kühler geworden ist,
also ich muss jeden Tag fast ein Nachthand wechseln tatsächlich, ja.
Ja, genau.
Müssen Sie die Kleidung wechseln in der Nacht?
Ja, genau, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, ich muss das Nachthand wechseln.
Okay, okay.
Seit 2 Wochen, leider nicht mehr.
Hab ich das so bemerkt, ja.
Also ich habe vorher gedacht, das war wegen der Hitze gewesen,
weil es so warm war draußen,
aber anscheinend war es nicht deswegen und ich mache mir jetzt groß Sorgen.
Also ich glaube, ich habe Krebs.
Was glauben Sie denn?
Ja, natürlich muss man diese Krebs auch auswissen,
aber man muss nichts an die schlimmste Ursache denken.
Deshalb braucht diese auch weitere Untersuchungen zur Bestätigung.
Das kann es an Sonntsein aussehen, das passt ja völlig, ja.
Das war bei meinem Vater genauso gewesen, ja,
und wahrscheinlich ist es bei mir auch so, oder?
Ihr Vater ist gestorben, oder?
Ja, der ist gestorben.
Okay, Woran ist gestorben?
Der hat auch Krebs gehabt, man wusste nicht, wann es lag.
Okay, natürlich müssen wir diese Krebs auch auswissen,
aber jetzt brauchen Sie keine Angst zu haben.
Ich habe schon Angst, deswegen bin ich ja da.
Ich habe schon Angst, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau, ja. Jetzt verstehe ich Sie, ganz gut.
Und haben Sie keine Schmerzen? Leiden Sie unter...
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen, ich mache mir nur große Sorgen.
Genau, leiden Sie unter Bauchschmerzen
oder haben Sie Schmerzen beim Wasserblasen, Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen beim Wasserblasen,
ich habe auch keine Schmerzen beim Stuhlgang.
Okay, leiden Sie unter Hassstorben oder Hassstraße?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, ich merke das nicht.
Okay, ich habe noch nie etwas Ernsthaftes gehabt.
Also ich bin auch nicht so oft beim Arzt,
aber jetzt ist es wirklich so, dass ich nicht mehr konnte,
ich musste vorbeischauen.
Genau, das ist schön, dass Sie hierher gekommen sind.
Genau, okay.
Haben Sie alle Geräte, die Sie, damit Sie mich genau durchschäten können,
haben Sie alles neben dem Krankenhaus, was Sie brauchen?
Oder soll ich mich doch von anders vorstellen lieber?
Ja, natürlich, wir arbeiten hier aus dem,
gibt es hier viele Abteilungen, viele paar Leute,
das mit ihren Beschwerden auch beschäftigen können.
Und nach dieser Gespräche werde ich auch mit dem Oberarzt
oder mit dem anderen Kollegen auch sprechen.
Dann werden wir darüber diskutieren, über ihre Beschwerden.
Und abschließend werden Sie bestmöglich beihand von uns bekommen.
Also ich muss mir keine Sorge machen, ja?
Genau, ja, verstehe ich.
Und, okay, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen haben Sie nachgeschweißt.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Abgeschlagenheit und Müde sein,
in den letzten drei Monaten, oder seit wann haben Sie diese Müde?
Ja, also die Müdigkeit habe ich gerade gesagt,
ich bin seit zwei Wochen ungefähr, die Müdigkeit.
Also, dass ich immer zunehmend merke,
dass wenn ich treppe, laufe zum Beispiel,
dass ich da nicht mehr so viel Kraft habe wie vorher,
oder wenn ich meinen Haushalt mache,
dass ich mich öfters hinlegen muss.
Oder jemand anderes die Arbeit machen lassen muss.
Das habe ich vorher nicht gehabt.
Entschuldigung, habe ich Sie mit gut gehört, weil Internet ist...
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Also ich habe in den letzten zwei Wochen
bemerkt, dass ich nicht mehr so viel Kraft habe wie vorher.
Also ich muss beim Haushalt, wenn ich den Haushalt mache,
mich öfters hinlegen oder eine Pause machen,
oder jemand anderes die Arbeit machen lassen.
Als wenn ich Sport gemacht hätte, ich war immer sportlich.
Ich bin immer viel gegangen und immer viele Schritte gemacht,
aber momentan schaffe ich das nicht mehr.
Okay, habe ich Sie richtig verstanden?
Sie waren auch beim Haushalt, ja?
Ja, wegen dieser Becherung.
Beim Haushalt war ich auch, ja genau.
Ich war schon vor zwei Wochen bei dem gewesen,
habe die Situation erklärt und der hat gesagt,
wir abwarten erstmal, das wird schon,
ich soll mich nicht so viel Gedanken machen.
Aber ich habe noch eine Erdnahme bei Ihnen?
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt diese Woche machen.
Ich sollte diese Woche noch mal vorbeikommen,
ich wollte jetzt Krankenhaus kommen,
ich brauch einen kompletten Checkup,
das nehme ich einmal durchchecken,
weil ich mache mir große Sorgen
und ich weiß nicht, was werden soll,
wenn ich sterben soll, oder so,
ich muss das alles organisieren.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie left, left, Knoten, Perlgelösserung bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe keine selber bemerkt, nein.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Ihr Augen oder Ihr Haut gerettet worden sind?
Nein.
Mein Haushalt hatte mich auch untersucht vor zwei Wochen,
er hat auch geguckt, ob irgendwas ist,
aber er sagt auch, er hat momentan nichts gefunden,
er hat mich aber nur körperlich untersucht,
mich abgehört, mich abgetastet,
aber er sagte momentan, es ist alles okay,
wir sollen erstmal warten
und es wäre, weil es weg so warm ist, deswegen wäre das.
Genau, okay, ich werde Sie auch komplett
und körperlich untersuchen,
Blut abnehmen werden wir auch.
Okay, ist Ihnen übel, oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie nicht erbrochen?
Nein.
Also ich esse ja nicht mehr so viel,
das will ich vielleicht, weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Nein, ich bekam keine.
Sind bei Ihnen Unfallerhaltung bekannt?
Okay, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre
aktuelle Vorgeschichte,
über Ihre Vorgeschichte an Sie stellen.
Leiden Sie unter einer der wichtigsten Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen,
ob es zum Beispiel Blutstuhlkrankheit oder Bluthochdrück.
Nein, ich stimme keine Medikamente rein,
ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen, ich bin sehr selten beim Arzt.
Okay, nehmen Sie Medikamente rein?
Nein, manchmal kauf ich mir Tabletten,
wenn ich Stress habe oder so, ansonsten eigentlich nichts.
Welche Tablette, wissen Sie das?
Also kommt drauf an, ich habe zu Hause Parats,
Damol, manchmal auch Ibuprofen,
das, was ich in der Apotheken kaufen kann.
Sie sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Also mein Blitztam ist raus,
vor Jahren schon.
Als Sie Kind waren, oder?
Ja, da war ich irgendwie 25 oder so.
Genau, ja.
Und ansonsten keine weitere Operationen?
Nein, ich bekam keine.
Okay.
Sind Sie im Vorstände geblieben?
Was meinen Sie, solche nicht?
Gegen Corona COVID-19?
Ja, ich habe drei Infektionen.
Sie haben gestern, dass Sie früher gut Sport treiben können.
Aber momentan wegen dieser Medikate und Abgeschleigenheit
können Sie nicht gut Sport treiben, können Sie nicht gut bewegen.
Genau, genauso.
Früher haben Sie was, haben Sie das erste Sport?
Ja, ich war oft schwimmen, wir haben Walking gemacht,
das heißt, wir sind meine Freundinnen,
wir sind immer raus und haben andere Schritte gemacht.
Ich habe mir ein bisschen mehr gewogen.
Ich war ja schon ein bisschen körperlich völlig gewesen
und ich wollte halt fit bleiben.
Deswegen haben wir das gemacht,
aber so richtig abnehmen konnte ich nicht.
Aber es hat mir gut getan.
Okay, okay.
Es geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Sind Sie schon in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, in der letzten Zeit in Holland war ich,
aber das ist ja nicht Ausland, in Holland.
Genau, ja, das ist normale Umgebung.
Das meine ich in Afrika-Regionen oder Anderen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lauchen Sie?
Gelegentlich, ich bin keine Kveste, auch ein Gelegentlich.
Ungefähr wie viel Zigaretten pro Tag?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Selten, vielleicht 10 im Jahr.
Seit 10 Jahren.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, ich habe gesagt,
seit ich rauche vielleicht 10 Zigaretten im Jahr.
Also sehr selten, sehr selten.
Genau, ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten.
Ab und zu weinen, aber nicht so oft.
Genau, ja.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Bitte?
Bitte meine, diese Frage nehmen Sie nicht persönlich,
dass eine...
Sehe ich aus, als wenn ich Drogen einnehmen würde?
Ja, genau.
Ist sie aus, als wenn ich Drogen einnehmen würde?
Nein, nein, Entschuldigung, ich muss Sie fragen,
ob Sie Drogen nehmen wegen dieser medizinischen Erkrankungen.
Das ist normale Routinefrage für die medizinische Erkrankungen.
Das sind dann für Sie Drogen? Also ich stimme keine Drogen ein,
aber ich muss routinämäßig fragen, deshalb habe ich gefragt.
So, okay.
Das ist gut, dass Sie nichts eingenommen haben und das ist...
Ja, natürlich, ich stimme keinen Drogen ein.
Ja.
Das sieht doch nicht aus wie ein Junkie.
Okay, ich möchte jetzt einfach fragen
über Ihre Frauen, an der Medizin fragen,
an sich stellen.
Wie könnte es sein, dass Sie jetzt schwanger sind,
wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Haben Sie mal geguckt, wie alt ich bin?
Ja, 54 Jahre alt.
Haben Sie schon mal, wie viele Frauen gebären damit, 54?
Ja, das ist klar, natürlich.
Und sind Sie jetzt...
Also ich habe mich schon, meine Wechseljahre,
ich bin längst durch, ehrlich gesagt.
Genau.
Und ich glaube nicht mehr, dass meine Gebärmung so funktioniert,
wie vorher tatsächlich.
Also ich glaube nichts, als ich schwanger bin.
Natürlich, okay.
Ich glaube, das wissen Sie auch.
Ja, besuchen Sie regelmäßig Frauen aus?
Zur Kontrolle?
Ja, ich war vor zwei Jahren zuletzt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Vorgeschichte, Familienanwesung an sich stellen.
Wie ist die Familienstatus?
Ich bin alleine ziehend.
Mein Mann hat sich getrennt von mir.
Ja.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei Stück.
Zwei Söhne oder...
Ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Sind die beide gesund?
Die sind gesund, die sind auch berufstückig,
sind selbstständig.
Die wohnen auch nicht mehr.
Also die wohnen schon noch mit mir,
aber die können noch alle selber machen eigentlich.
Der eine ist jetzt volljährig,
und der andere wird volljährig.
Das ist schon.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, aber ich habe keinen Kontakt zu ihr.
Okay.
Sie habe gesagt, dass Ihr Vater gestorben sei.
Wann ist Erfst gestorben?
Also da muss ich kurz rechnen.
Mein Vater war...
Er ist vor zehn Jahren...
Ne, vor 15 Jahren ist er gestorben.
Anwesend, kräft der Erkrankung?
Das wissen wir nicht.
Er hat überall gestreut einen Krebs gehabt.
Er war überall gestreut und die Ärzte konnte nichts machen.
Und er ist dann innerhalb von sechs Monaten verstorben.
Okay.
Ja, das tut mir leid.
Das ist natürlich schwierig.
Wenn ich auch sterben sollte,
muss ich vieles klären.
Deswegen muss ich das mit Ihnen besprechen
oder mit Ihrem Team besprechen.
Ich habe auch zügige Antworten.
Wir werden hier alles um Ihnen zu helfen.
Deshalb...
Und auch abschließend werden Sie hier besser geworden.
Das sagen Sie, dass es mir besser geht?
Ja, genau. Wir bei uns.
Und unser Team haben große Erfahrungen
über alle Krankheiten, über alle Krankgeschichten.
Kann das denn auch etwas anderes sein außer Krebs?
Auch Krebs kann auch andere viele Gründe haben,
diese Beschwerden.
Zum Beispiel Blutarmut oder andere Erkrankungen
oder andere Ursachen können diese Beschwerden perursachen.
Deshalb müssen wir weiter unter Suchung machen.
Aber Sie glauben auch, dass es Krebs haben muss, oder?
Wie Krebs?
Sie glauben auch, dass es Krebs haben muss, oder?
Müssen wir Krebs auswischen?
Immer müssen wir das im Kopf haben.
Aber man muss nicht diese Krebs immer an den Krebs denken.
Ja, warum soll ich denn sonst denken?
Was soll es denn sonst sein?
Blutarmut oder andere Erkrankungen auch können haben.
Hepatitis oder so.
Viele Erkrankungen, viele Ursachen haben diese Beschwerden.
Ist Ihr Mutter noch?
Ja, meine Mutter lebt noch.
Hat sie eine Erkrankung?
Sie hat Bluthochdruck, Colesterol erhöht und eine Schilddrüsenerkrankung.
Sie nimmt auf jeden Fall Medikamente dafür ein.
Was machen Sie aus der Rufti?
Ich bin Sekretärin.
Seht ihr beide arbeit zufrieden mit der Arbeit?
Ja, ich mache den Job jetzt seit 30 Jahren.
Ich bin zufrieden eigentlich.
Ich hatte immer viel zu tun.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, wie gesagt, in den letzten 2 Wochen muss ich immer mein Nachtherm wechseln.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Schlafen.
Nur manchmal durchschlafen.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Nachschweißnummer?
Ja, genau.
Frau Schmidt, ich habe von meiner Seite alle wichtige Fragen an Sie gestellt.
Ich möchte eine Prozess-Somfassung für Sie machen.
Wenn Sie etwas herzubekommen möchten, können Sie gerne beheben.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit 3 Monaten 40 kg angewitzt haben.
In den letzten 2 Wochen haben Sie Nachschweiß und eine Abgeschleunheitmöglichkeit bemerkt.
Sie waren vor 2 Wochen beim Haushalt.
Sie haben auch ein paar Utilsuchungen bei Ihnen gemacht.
Damals war alles unaufgeregt.
Aber trotzdem sind Sie hierher bei uns gekommen.
Es ist gut, dass Sie diese Entscheidung getroffen haben.
Nach Schweiß haben Sie Gewissabnahme und ein bisschen Fieber bemerkt.
Aber Sie haben nicht gemessen.
Nein, ich habe nicht gemessen.
Okay, haben Sie Beine oder geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Nein, das bin ich nicht aufgefahren.
Hautverfärbung?
Das bin ich auch nicht aufgefahren.
Ich habe auch keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen.
Was passiert denn jetzt?
Was machen Sie in den Frühen?
Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ich werde Sie von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde Sie mit dem Oberarzt sprechen.
Nach dieser Besprechung werde ich nach Ihnen kommen.
Ich sage Ihnen, was Sie tun.
Ich werde Sie auch ein paar diagnostische Maßnahmen durchführen.
Zum Beispiel ein Bauhultraschall durchführen.
Ein Röntgen Torax durchführen.
Ein Rkg durchführen.
Um ein unfassendes Bild zu haben.
Umfassendes Bild.
Damit wir richtige Diagnose stellen können.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Haben unsere Kollegen ein paar Fragen?
Haben Sie eine Hormon-Erzatstherapie?
Ich habe eine Salbe aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr genommen.
Ich habe sie genommen.
Aber ich muss sie nicht mehr nehmen.
Ich habe sie nicht mehr genommen.
Warum muss sie sie nicht mehr nehmen?
Weil ich die Beschwerden nicht mehr hatte.
Das war in den Wechseljahren.
Meine Frau hat gesagt, weil ich diese Hitzewallungen bekommen habe.
Sie hat mir eine Salbe aufgeschrieben.
Das hat geholfen.
Und irgendwann braucht es sich nicht mehr zu nehmen.
Das ist schon.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich habe nicht mehr so viel Appetit als vorher.
Ich habe früher mehr gegessen.
Lassen Sie Mammographie aufnehmen?
Vor zwei Jahren war ich bei einem Gologen.
Er hat alles kontrolliert.
Aber alles war okay.
Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Ich habe sie nicht kontrolliert.
Aber alles war okay.
Haben Sie Schmilbulutung bemerkt?
Nein.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit aufgeregt?
Ja, ich bin schon aufgeregt.
Weil ich wissen will, was ich habe.
Ich habe Angst.
Ich denke, dass ich Krebs habe.
Ich habe Angst, ob man das behandeln kann.
Was ich mit meinen Kindern mache.
Ich muss mich vorbereiten.
Ich muss das schnell wissen, damit ich arbeiten kann.
Damit ich planen kann.
Weil ich gesehen habe, wie das bei meinem Vater war.
Da waren Sie in der letzten Zeit nervös?
Aggressive oder?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich bin ein ruhiger Mensch.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, wir können anfangen.
Herr Oberarst, hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Bitte schön.
Frau Angelika Schmidt ist 54 Jahre alt.
72 kg schwer.
1,74 m groß.
Frau Angelika Schmidt hat sich heute bei uns seit 3 Monaten
wegen einer Gewichtsabnahme 5 kg schwer.
5 kg?
15 kg.
Gewichtsabnahme in der letzten 3 Monaten vorgestellt.
15 kg schwer.
Die Patientin hat seit 2 Wochen einen Nachschweiß.
Die Patientin muss wegen der Nachschweiß aufmachen
und Kleidung wechseln.
Die Patientin hat eine Insomnia
in Form durch Schlachtsturungen.
Die Patientin hat eine Fatüge.
Leider unter Fatüge.
Seit 2 Wochen.
Fatüge und Inapäters.
Früher haben die Patientin gut Sport getrieben.
Heutzutage können er nicht gut Sport schreiben
wegen der Fatüge.
Vor 2 Wochen war die Patientin beim Hausarzt.
Hausarzt hat eine allgemeine
interneistische und körperliche Untersuchung gemacht.
Die Patientin hat eine Allgemeine und körperliche Untersuchung gemacht.
Die Ergebnisse waren unabhängig.
Was hat die Hausarzt gemacht?
Welche Untersuchung?
Und hat auch Lungen,
Oskultation, Herzoskultation und Perkussion
und körperliche Untersuchung gemacht.
Genau, wurde durchgeführt.
Die Frage nach Sikleralichterus und Lampfgrößen.
Nach was?
Sikleralichterus.
Okay.
Vergrößerung der Lampfknoten.
Die Hautverfärbung wurde verneint.
Die Vegetarine an der Mese
sei unaufgleich bis auf
oben genannten Symptomen.
Die Patientin hat auch Fieber gemerkt.
Aber
er dachte
oder sie dachte,
dass die Fieber wegen
Hitze
vorkommen sein.
Sie dachte, dass sie
die Fieber wegen der Hitze
gehabt hätte.
Und Allergie und Unverträglichkeiten
wurden verneint.
Und die Frage nach
es gebe keine
relevante Vorerkrankungen
bei dieser Patientin.
Die Patientin
nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Nur bei Bedarf über Profen oder andere Schmerzen
oder andere Tablette wegen Kopfschmerzen.
Sie nehmen die Patientin ein.
Die Patientin, Frau Schmidt,
sei im Alter von 25 Jahren
appendiktomiert worden.
Ansonsten keine weiteren Operationen
bei dieser Patientin.
Sie sei in den nächsten Jahren
und Frau Anamnese sei unaufgleich.
Sie war vorständig.
Die Frage nach Auslandreise
wurde vermeint.
Die Patientin
raufe selten.
Alkohol trinkt sie selten.
Und drogen von uns wurde vermeint.
Die Patientin sei alleine erziehend.
Sie sei geschieden, habe zwei Kinder, die beide gesund sind.
Sie haben eine Schwester.
Die Patientin hatte keine Kontakte mehr.
Der Vater der Patientin
sei vor 15 Jahren an einer Krebs gestorben.
Aber wer der Krebs sei nicht bekannt.
Konnte die Patientin das nicht?
Selbst nicht.
Sie wussten nicht,
welcher Krebs es ist.
Oder wusste der Vater das nicht?
Oder die Ärzte nicht?
Die Patienten wussten das nicht.
Das habe ich so verstanden.
Die Patientin wusste sie selbst nicht.
Sie weiß nur,
die Krebserkrankung von einer viel gesteuerten Krebs.
Die Patienten wussten das nicht.
Die Patientin war noch lebt.
Und leider an einer Artilleripartone.
Eine Hypercholestermin.
Und eine schulterischen
Funksonstürung.
Und die Patientin war noch lebt.
Eine Funksonstürung.
Die Patientin war noch lebt.
Und eine Schuld concentration.
Das war ein
Fieberiche, ja, vielbare, oder?
Und Gewitzabnahme in den letzten drei Monaten,
50 Kilogramm Gewitzabnahme, ja.
Diese Betrachtentwürme.
Und die Differenzialdionusen kommen,
als die Differenzialdionusen kommen, eine Anämie.
Und eine Autoimmunerkrankung.
Und eine Lebererkrankung in Betracht.
Welche Autoimmunerkrankung kann es sein?
Autoimmunherpatitis, zum Beispiel.
Autoimmunherpatitis auch.
Eine Anämie, auch eine...
äh...
ja...
Multiple Myeloma, zum Beispiel, auch könnte es sein.
In Betracht.
Zur weiteren Abklärung, wo wir diese Patienten
zuerst köpfe ich untersuchen.
Untersuchen.
Dann von der Patientin Blut abnehmen.
Und ein Bauch-Ultraschall durchführen.
Optomanosynografie und EKG, wo ich fahren lassen.
Ein Röntgantorax, wo ich fahren lassen.
Zwei Ebenen.
Äh...
Und ja, sollte sich meine Verlaptose bestätigen,
wo ich diese Patienten aufnehme.
Ich lasse sie aufnehmen und Zugang legen.
Und äh...
ein Infusiongabel, wo ich auch verabreischen.
Äh...
Infusion, was für eine Infusion?
Infusiongabe, äh...
Ja, eine normale...
Kann sie nicht trinken?
Kann sie trinken, natürlich.
Ja, kann sie trinken.
Infusiongabel...
Muss man nicht...
Wenn sie Schmerzen hat, natürlich...
Hat die Schmerzen?
Keine Schmerzen. Deshalb brauche ich keine Schmerzmittel geben.
Sie kann trinken.
Sie müssen ihr keine Infusion geben,
als sei denn, sie wollen etwas verändern.
Ja, ja, genau.
Ist sie... ist sie...
ist sie korrektisch oder ist sie...
ist sie exikiert? Hat sie ne Exikose?
Äh... keine Exikose.
Dann kann sie trinken.
Genau. Ja.
Oder? Kann sie... kann sie essen?
Kann sie essen?
Keine Appetit, aber kann sie essen, ja.
Sie kann essen, also...
Vor allem müssten sie keine Infusion geben,
aber sie können...
Einfach psychologisch können sie eine geben,
um den Wehenzugang aufzulassen,
aber vor allem braucht sie keine Infusion eigentlich.
Genau.
Sie brauchen aktuell keine Medikation, so wie ich es verstanden habe.
Sie hat keine Beschwerden.
Genau, keine Medikation, keine Infusion.
Aber muss sich eine Blutentnahme...
Was kontrollieren Sie da?
Blut, was kontrollieren Sie?
So heißt Entzündungwerke.
Ich wollte kontrollieren und Blutbild kontrollieren.
Blutzängung, Geschwindigkeit und Serapie,
habe ich gesagt, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte
und Kolestarswerte,
wollte ich kontrollieren.
Ja.
Schilddrüsenwerte?
Wie bitte?
Schilddrüsenwerte, Schilddrüsenwerte.
Genau, ja, Schilddrüsenwerte,
beide Mutter auch eine...
ja, bekannt.
Warum ist aber die Schilddrüsen noch wichtig?
Schilddrüsenwerte können auch...
Warum sollten Sie die Schilddrüsenwerte,
auch wenn sie keine Erkrankung hat, abnehmen?
Auch wenn sie keine Schilddrüsenerkrankung hat,
warum sollten Sie die Schilddrüsenwerte mit abnehmen?
Das TSH, wofür ist das wichtig?
Genau, TSH kann Gewichtsabnahme auslösen.
Nein, nein, nein, ich meine...
Okay, aber ich meine eher, Sie haben ja gesagt,
Sie nehmen die Nierenwerte ab, Leberwerte ab,
aber die Schilddrüsenwerte,
das TSH sollten Sie unbedingt mit abnehmen.
Warum?
Kontrastmittelwechselwirkung, ja.
Nein, wahrscheinlich würde man bei der Patientin
auch genau ein CT machen,
mit Kontrastmitteln
und dann müssten Sie das nachbestimmen,
am besten machen Sie das direkt sofort mit.
Wenn haben Sie alle Werte da,
dann kann man vielleicht morgen übermorgen das CT machen.
Das ist immer schon mal da
und Sie müssen die Patienten nochmal mit abnehmen,
das ist nicht so.
Man kann das nachmelden, aber direkt im einen durchmachen.
Okay, gut.
Kann die Patientin auch eine Schilddrüsenüberfunktion haben?
Kann das die Patientin auch erklären?
Genau, ja, kann Sie haben.
Diese Zentrumen, Schilddrüsenüberfunktion,
oder Schilddrüsenüberfunktion auch,
können diese Zentrumen auch peru Sachen.
Okay, aber Sie haben recht,
wahrscheinlich, das klingt eher so nach einer maligen Erkrankung,
mit dem ausgesprochenen Gewichtsabnahme
und dem Machtschweiß.
Wie würden Sie das der Patientin dann erklären,
dass sie wahrscheinlich eine schlimme Erkrankung hat,
eine vielleicht auch tödliche Erkrankung hat?
Wie würden Sie das ihr beibringen?
Ja, ich würde so erst, ja, erklären,
das ist eine Erkrankung
und diese Erkrankung ist behandbar, können wir auch sagen.
Kann man eine Krebserkrankung immer behandeln?
Nicht alle, aber muss man...
Also man kann die behandeln, aber man kann die nicht heilen, ne?
Ja, genau, man kann die nicht heilen.
Die Patientin weiß ja auch, dass ihr Vater an Krebs verstorben ist,
also sie weiß, was auf sie zukommt.
Okay, machen Sie mal weiter.
Wie würden Sie das erklären?
Genau, zum Beispiel Frau Schmidt hat diese große Sorge
über diese Erkrankung
und wenn wir diese Diagnose festgestellt haben,
dann können wir natürlich, wie Sie gesagt haben, erklären.
Zum Beispiel Frau Schmidt haben wir eine klasse Erkrankung,
die auch sehr festgestellt hat.
Diese Erkrankung ist eine schlimme Erkrankung.
Aber sie brauchen keine Angst zu haben.
Wir werden hier in diesem Krankenhaus alles tun, um Ihnen zu helfen.
Es gibt bestimmte Therapiemethoden für diese Krankheit
und es gibt auch moderne Therapiemethoden
in diesem Krankenhaus, in diesem Abteilung.
Wir informieren Sie rechtzeitig über weitere Schritte immer
und hier müssen Sie bei uns bleiben für weitere Behandlung.
Genau, okay.
Alles klar, mich fand das gut, haben Sie gut gemacht?
Ja, danke Ihnen.
Sie haben nur vergessen, bei der Anonyse nach dem Stuhlgang zu fragen
und nach dem Wasserlassen, haben Sie, glaube ich, nicht gefragt?
Oder haben Sie das gefragt?
Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Okay, dann habe ich das vergessen.
Aber haben Sie gut gemacht, bin ich gut.
Ihr Deutsch ist sehr gut, nicht schlecht.
Danke Ihnen.
Ja, ab dem Anfang ein bisschen habe ich Pause gemacht.
Welche Beschwerde muss ich nachfragen?
Sie reden etwas zu schnell, Sie müssen etwas langsamer sprechen.
Genau, ja.
Sie sind etwas zu schnell unterwegs, ein bisschen langsamer, aber sehr gut.
Genau, meine Mutter spricht auch sehr schnell,
deshalb ist es spontan aufgetrittene.
Ja, verstanden, okay, ein bisschen ruhiger.
Ich rede auch immer schnell, aber man muss ein bisschen ruhiger sprechen,
damit man auch besser verständlich ist für den Gegenüber.
Ja, stimmt.
Super, noch jemand hat jemand Fragen oder Anmerkungen?
Also das Thema war heute eigentlich Besymptomatik, um zu gucken,
man weiß nicht, was die Patientin hat.
Sie hat Besymptomatik und haben Sie gut gemacht.
Ja, danke Ihnen.
Okay, danke Ihnen auch.
Ich habe immer noch Fragen.
Ja, müssen wir diese Patientin stationär aufnehmen?
Gute Frage, man muss das nicht machen, weil sie hat keine Beschwerde.
Man kann die Untersuchungen auch Ambulanz machen,
man sollte aber einen Zeitnanten mitgeben.
Also man kann ihr sagen, wir machen heute Ultraschall,
wie der Kollege das gesagt hat, wir machen heute das Röntgen
und wir machen heute die Blutabnahme
und dann kann man sie nochmal selber hat, ambulant,
für den CT-Abdomen und CT-Torax-Knochenmark-Kfunktionen,
sollte man aber schon stationär eventuell machen,
muss man aber auch nicht.
Man kann sie ambulant belasten tatsächlich, ja, man muss sie nicht aufnehmen.
Weil sie hat keine Beschwerden, sie braucht keine Medikamente,
sie braucht keine Infusion, sie braucht keine unterstützende Therapie.
Das ist alles gut.
Ihr Gewicht ist noch okay, mit 72 Kilogramm und 1774
ist ungefähr noch Idealgewicht.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Führen wir alle CT gleichzeitig durch?
In der Regel macht man einen CT-Torax-Abdomen
und man würde vielleicht noch ein separates Schädel CT machen.
Also vom Schädel.
Insbesondere wenn sie zum Beispiel ein Multibismiolom haben sollte,
kann man das ja da sehen.
Im Schädel kann man das ganz gut sehen.
Ansonsten das MRT kann man nicht komplett durchnehmen,
aber das CT kann man einmal durchschießen.
Vielen Dank.
Insbesondere CT-Torax-Abdomen kann man zusammen machen,
sollte man, weil diese Patienten auch zusammen machen.
Danke schön.
Ja.
Danke Ihnen.
Okay, klar.
Was man auch machen sollte,
man sollte die Patienten, müssen Sie da dran denken,
dass man sie im Prinzip auch ihr sagen kann,
dass man sie bei den anderen Abteilungen vorstellen wird.
Insbesondere klinikologische Abteilung,
vielleicht urologische Abteilung,
dass man, haben Sie aber auch gesagt,
dass man mit denen in Kontakt ist und im Team arbeitet.
Wir fangen an mit dem, wie der Kollege gesagt hat,
mit Dröntgen-Torax.
Wir fangen an mit der Bootabnahme natürlich,
EKG und Sonorabdomen.
Das kann man alles in der Ambulanz machen,
wenn man Zeit hat.
Ansonsten kann man das Ultraschall auch stationär machen.
Und dann macht man in der Regel, je nachdem,
welche Richtung es geht,
CT-Abdomen-Torax.
Und dann guckt man weiter.
Und dann halt Funktion oder keine Funktion.
Vielleicht hat es eine Lymphadenopathie.
Man muss mal gucken, ob man einen Lymphknun entnimmt,
wenn sie Kupsyndrom hat.
Das ist etwas anderes,
aber das ist dann die Weiterführende Diagnostik,
die wir natürlich um den Tag arbeiten müssen.
Okay?
Im Chat gibt es eine Frage,
welche Unterhörungen wir beginnen müssen,
erst die nekuläubische Unterhörungen?
Nein, habe ich ja gerade gesagt.
Erst mal Röntgen-Torax-Bootabnahme,
EKG und dann Abdomen-Sono.
Abdomen-Sono ist das Wichtigste.
Dann können Sie die Leber sehen,
die Milz sehen, die Nieren sehen, den Darm sehen,
den Utterus sehen, das Pfangferst sehen.
Wenn Sie gut Sonografieren können,
die Haarenblase können Sie sehen.
Und im Anschluss kann man dann,
wenn man dort nichts finden sollte
oder auch etwas finden sollte,
gezielt dann auch mit Computertomographie arbeiten,
gegebenenfalls sogar mit MRT.
Je nachdem, in welche Richtung es geht.
Wenn Sie etwas im Pankreis sehen,
dann können Sie natürlich auch
mit einer endoscorpischen Untersuchung
eine Funktion machen, zum Beispiel.
Es kommt darauf an,
welcher Tumor es ist,
ob es aber ein Tumor ist,
ob Sie eine Bronzoskopie machen müssen,
um von den Blünffknoten mediasional etwas zu nehmen
oder auch gezielt von dem
von dem Grundhärt, den Sie sehen würden
oder ob Sie aufgrund von Blutveränderungen
eine Knochenmarktsfunktion machen müssen.
Das ist dann immer spezifisch,
je nachdem, in welche Richtung es geht.
Antihilftest auf.
Können Sie einen Verlauf machen,
müssen Sie nicht sofort machen.
Wenn Sie nichts finden,
das ist keine Routine Diagnostik,
wenn Sie für größere Blünffknoten sehen
oder so etwas, das ist sinnvoll, definitiv.
Oder wenn ein Patient,
ein Risikopatient ist,
wenn er wechselnde Geschäftspartner hat,
wenn er Drogen abnimmt oder dergleichen,
das ist immer so eine Sache,
aber ist sicherlich eine gute Diagnostik.
Ich wünsche allen einen schönen Sonntag
und viel Erfolg bei den Prüfungen.
Gleichfalls habe Ihnen auch.
Danke.